I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Good morning, lady. How are ya?
我是詹娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作独家《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎们。早上好，女士。你好吗？
Hey, I said good morning today. I noticed. Lady, I posted like an extreme close-up of my face on Instagram today holding my office ladies coffee mug because I was just so excited to see you even though it's on a Zoom and record our podcast today. It's the highlight of my week. Oh, same. Absolutely.
嘿，我今天说过早上好了。我注意到了。女士，我今天在Instagram上发布了一张我脸部极近距离的特写照片，手里拿着我们的办公室女郎马克杯，因为我很高兴见到你，尽管是通过Zoom录制我们今天的播客。这是我一周中最精彩的时刻。哦，我也是。绝对是的。
Well, I think we should get into this episode. You mean the one called The Lover? The Lover. Why am I saying it like that? The Lover. It's hard not to say it like that. I know. Remember those friends of yours that would call one another Lover?
好吧，我觉得我们应该开始讨论这一集了。你是说那集叫《情人》的吗？《情人》。我为什么要那样说？《情人》。很难不那样说。我知道。还记得你那些互称情人的朋友吗？
Yes. They would like this episode. Oh my gosh. They really would. Lover, I thought you were going to pick up the grocery's Lover. Okay, I'm standing right here. I'm your neighbor and I'm standing right here. We hear a lot of nicknames that Michael calls Pam's mom.
是的。他们会喜欢这一集的。哦天哪。他们真的会。情人，我以为你要去买杂货了，情人。好吧，我就站在这里。我是你的邻居，我就站在这里。我们听到迈克尔给潘的妈妈起了很多绰号。
Thankfully, none of them are Lover. I know, but they're still so awkward. Boo, Pickle. Pickles and Boo. It is season six, episode seven, written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitsky and directed by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitsky. Although Lee Eisenberg is the only director credited because of that DGA thing that we told you about the last time this happened.
谢天谢地，没有一个是“情人”。我知道，但它们还是让人觉得很尴尬。宝贝，小黄瓜。小黄瓜和宝贝。这是第六季第七集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基执导。尽管由于我们上次遇到这种情况时告诉过你们的DGA规定，李·艾森伯格是唯一署名的导演。
Right, right. Little tidbit for you. It was edited by Gary Levy, Greg, and Paul's cousin. Oh, a guest editor. Guest editor. I'm going to hit you with a summary. I was hoping you would. It's very quick.
对，对。给你们一个小花絮。这一集由加里·列维剪辑，他是格雷格和保罗的表弟。哦，客座剪辑师。客座剪辑师。我要给你们讲讲剧情概要。我希望你能这么做。非常简短。
That's what she said. Pam and Jim's post-Honeymoon glow is doled by the horrifying news that Michael is dating Pam's mom. Meanwhile, Dwight gives Jim a gift that turns out to be a listening device. I mean, that's it. That's it. I summed it up. You did.
她就是这么说的。潘和吉姆度蜜月后的甜蜜被一个可怕的消息打破了：迈克尔在和潘的妈妈约会。与此同时，德怀特送给吉姆一件礼物，结果发现是一个窃听器。我的意思是，就是这样。就是这样。我总结完了。你总结得很对。
So, this episode really just has a very distinct A story, a very distinct B story. Fast fact number one, we're going to start with that A story which I am calling Pam is mad. Pam is pissed off. We had a fan question from Kiana and Andres from Williams, Oregon. Who said, we love ourselves an angry Pam. Our question is, what did you do to get yourself into this mode of angry? Was it difficult since Pam is usually pretty calm?
所以，这一集确实有一个非常鲜 A线和一个非常鲜明的B线。快讯第一条，我们将从A线开始，我称之为“潘疯了”。潘气炸了。我们收到了来自俄勒冈州威廉姆斯的基亚娜和安德烈斯的粉丝提问。他们说，我们超爱生气的潘。我们的问题是，你做了什么来让自己进入这种生气模式的？这很难吗，因为潘通常都很冷静？
Oh, Angela. This was so difficult for me. As an actor, this episode, I really, really struggled. Well, I thought you crushed it, Jenna. I loved it. I laughed so much watching it. And for once, it was nice that someone was more angry than my character. I guess I can see that.
哦，安吉拉。这对我来说太难了。作为一名演员，这一集我真的、真的很挣扎。嗯，我觉得你演得太棒了，詹娜。我很喜欢。看的时候我笑得前仰后合。而且破天荒地，有人比我的角色更生气，这感觉真好。我想我能理解。
Well, for me, Angela, I just really struggled with how confrontational Pam was in this episode because I never felt her as a confrontational person. So does Pam get mad? Oh, sure, she does. But she's a silent sufferer. Does that make sense? Oh, yeah. It does make sense.
好吧，对安吉拉来说，我只是真的很纠结潘在这一集里为什么这么具有对抗性，因为我从没觉得她是一个具有对抗性的人。所以潘会生气吗？哦，当然会。但她是默默承受的那种。这说得通吗？哦，是的。确实说得通。
But in this one, she is almost like a hostile teenager. I had a lot of conversations with the creative team about this because I just could not make that leap from the Pam I had been playing to the Pam that was scripted in this episode. And what we decided was that everyone has a breaking point that makes them behave out of character for themselves. And this was it. Michael dating Pam's mom was the thing that was going to show us a whole new side of Pam. I agree with that.
但在这一集里，她几乎就像一个充满敌意的青少年。我为此与创意团队进行了很多沟通，因为我实在无法跨越我一直在扮演的潘和这一集剧本里的潘之间的鸿沟。我们最终决定的是，每个人都有一个爆发点，会让他们做出不符合自己性格的行为。这就是那个点。迈克尔和潘的妈妈约会这件事，将向我们展示潘全新的一面。我赞同这一点。
I mean, you know we all have someone that is in our lives. And if they became part of our family, we'd be like, ah, ah, ah, no, no, no, no, no. So I believed it. Yeah. Strangely, even watching this episode, I was like, did I do it? Was it like, it just doesn't seem like Pam to me. It's so crazy. Jenna, not only did you do it, but Azure BFF, I have to brag on you a little bit.
我的意思是，你知道我们生活中都有这样一个人。如果他们成了我们的家人，我们会觉得，啊，啊，啊，不，不，不，不，不。所以我相信了。是的。奇怪的是，甚至在看这一集的时候，我都觉得，我演好了吗？就好像，这看起来不太像潘。太疯狂了。詹娜，你不仅演好了，而且作为你的闺蜜，我必须稍微夸夸你。
I found an article in researching this episode that I wanted to read to you. Okay. It was written by Nathan Rabine for the AV Club. And it's still on their website. I'm just going to share a little bit of it. Nathan writes, many years ago, back when I worked at a thrift store, a singularly unpleasant co-worker I'd had a bitter falling out with, ambled up to me and awkwardly asked for the phone number of one of my sisters.
我在研究这一集时发现了一篇文章，我想读给你听。好的。这是南森·拉宾为《AV俱乐部》写的。它现在还在他们的网站上。我只分享一小部分。南森写道，许多年前，当我还在一家旧货店工作时，有一个关系特别不融洽、曾有过深刻矛盾的同事，慢悠悠地走到我面前，尴尬地向我要我其中一个姐妹的电话号码。
I will never forget my reaction. Without thought, without premeditation, I shouted, no. And stormed away in a huff. I did not merely refuse his request. I responded with revulsion, visceral horror, and something resembling rage. I am not proud of how I reacted, but if I had to do it over again, I would respond the same way. It really was the only sane reaction.
我永远不会忘记我的反应。不假思索，毫无预谋，我大喊：不。然后气冲冲地走开了。我不仅仅是拒绝了他的请求，我的反应充满了厌恶、发自内心的恐惧，以及某种类似愤怒的情绪。我并不为自己的反应感到骄傲，但如果让我重来一次，我还是会做出同样的反应。这真的是唯一理智的反应。
There's something deeply unnerving about our friends, our co-workers, having sex with our relatives that grows infinitely creepier the less sure we are about the friends or co-workers in question. I'm not just saying this because I am deeply, deeply repressed. So I knew exactly how Jim and Pam felt when they found out that Michael had, in his deliciously, pointlessly formal turn of phrase, taken a lover. And the lover in question was Pam's mom. The writing and the acting really sold the can't miss premise.
我们的朋友、同事和我们的亲戚发生性关系，这种事有着某种让人深感不安的诡异感，而对于当事朋友或同事的不确定性越高，这种诡异感就会无限放大。我这么说不仅仅是因为我内心有着深深的压抑。所以我完全明白吉姆和潘在发现迈克尔用他那种精妙绝伦却又毫无意义的正式措辞“找了个情人”时的感受。而这个所谓的情人竟然是潘的妈妈。剧本和演技真的完美支撑了这个不容错失的设定。
It was a half hour of awkward awesomeness. And I'm not even mentioning the niftiness of Ryan's fedora of mystery. Oh my gosh. I love that article. Isn't that so great? I thought you would feel affirmed in your performance. I do. And basically what he is saying is what Jean and Lee kept saying to me every day.
这是令人尴尬到极点又精彩绝伦的半小时。我甚至还没提到瑞恩那顶神秘软呢帽的绝妙之处呢。哦天哪。我太喜欢那篇文章了。是不是很棒？我想你会对自己的表演感到释怀的。我是。基本上他说的就是吉恩和李每天对我说的话。
They were like, you cannot help this. This is coming out of you and you can't stop it. That was their direction. I agree with Nathan. Amazing. Also, his response to his co-worker was so hilarious. All right. Moving us to fast fact number two.
他们说，你无法控制这个。这是从你内心爆发出来的，你停不下来。那是他们的导演指导。我同意南森的看法。太棒了。还有，他对同事的反应太搞笑了。好了。让我们进入快讯第二条。
This one is all about our B story, which I'm calling Dwight Records Jim. I got curious. Oh, I did too. I wonder if we got curious about the same things. Here was what I wanted to know. I was like Dwight is committing a crime, right? Yeah. This is a crime.
这一条完全关于我们的B线剧情，我称之为“德怀特监视吉姆”。我很好奇。哦，我也是。我想知道我们好奇的是不是同一件事。这是我想知道的。我想，德怀特是在犯罪吧？对。这是犯罪。
Pretty sure. I looked it up. Would mom detectives know? By the way, this whole storyline, I made a note to myself. Remember this for mom detectives. In 38 states, you can record a private conversation with another person and you only need one person to know that there's a recording happening. It's called one party consent.
基本上是的。我查过了。妈妈侦探会知道吗？顺便说一句，这个整条故事线，我给自己记了个笔记。记住这个给妈妈侦探。在38个州，你可以录制你与另一个人的私人对话，并且你只需要一个人知道录音正在发生。这被称为一方同意。
So would the party then be Dwight? Is Dwight the consent party? Yes. Oh. So he is recording. Well, I guess he's not in there. Exactly. Yeah.
那么当事人会是德怀特吗？德怀特是同意方吗？是的。哦。所以他在录音。好吧，我想他不在里面。完全正确。是的.
Basically, he would need someone like Creed and cahoots with him. Basically everyone who is talking to Jim would need to know they're being recorded. But there are 12 states that have a two-party consent law and that means that everybody being recorded has to give their consent to being recorded. Right. So these states are California, Delaware, Florida, Illinois, Maryland, Massachusetts, Montana, Nevada, New Hampshire, Washington, and Pennsylvania. So he is breaking the law.
基本上，他需要像克里德这样的人与他同谋。基本上所有与吉姆谈话的人都需要知道他们正在被录音。但有12个州实行双方同意法，这意味着被录音的每个人都必须同意被录音。对。所以这些州是加利福尼亚州、特拉华州、佛罗里达州、伊利诺伊州、马里兰州、马萨诸塞州、蒙大拿州、内华达州、新罕布什尔州、华盛顿州和宾夕法尼亚州。所以他在违法。
He is breaking the law. Now there are exceptions. You can videotape or record anything in a public space, but this is not a public space, where you can record a private conversation in a private space if you reasonably suspect that the person you're recording is about to commit or is in the process of committing a violent crime. Oh. None of these things apply.
他在违法。现在也有例外。你可以在公共空间录像或录制任何东西，但这并不是公共空间，或者如果你有合理怀疑你正在录音的人即将或正在进行暴力犯罪，你可以在私人空间录制私人对话。哦。这些都不适用。
What Dwight is doing is totally illegal. In fact, in Pennsylvania, it is a felony in the third degree. And if he was convicted, he could face three and a half years to seven years in prison and a fine of up to $15,000. And you know who would have known that? Dwight. Dwight. He's knowingly breaking the law.
德怀特做的事完全是违法的。事实上，在宾夕法尼亚州，这是三级重罪。如果他被定罪，他将面临三年半到七年的监禁以及最高15,000美元的罚款。你知道谁会知道这个吗？德怀特。德怀特。他是明知故犯。
He is. And what does he get out of it? Nothing. Eight hours of paper talk. Eight hours of, yeah, sales calls. Paper talk. All right, Angela. It's fast fact number three.
他是。他从中得到了什么？什么都没有。八小时的纸张交谈。八小时的，是的，销售电话。纸张交谈。好吧，安吉拉。快讯第三条。
You know what that means. Angela's digital clutter, that makes me laugh, I forgot how crazy that is. Sam made that. This is making me laugh and he made it to sound like The Matrix, which is because he knows me and he gets me and I love him for it. All right, fast fact three from my digital clutter. Remember guys, this may or may not pay off. Just remember that.
你知道这意味着什么。安吉拉的数字杂乱文件夹，这让我觉得好笑，我忘了这有多疯狂了。萨姆做的这个。这让我觉得好笑，他把它做得像《黑客帝国》一样，因为他了解我，他懂我，我为此爱死他了。好的，来自我的数字杂乱文件夹的快讯三。大家记住，这可能会有回报，也可能没有。只要记住这一点。
Oh, I feel like you reminding us of that. Okay. Maybe means you think it won't, but I have faith in you. So the week we filmed this episode in my digital clutter was an email exchange between myself, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup every day, and Pamela Santori, who sat next to Kenneth Paul and did the makeup in the chair right next to me. Yes. Oh, how wonderful.
哦，我觉得你是在提醒我们。好吧。也许这意味着你觉得不会，但我对你有信心。所以我们拍摄这一集的那个星期，在我的数字杂乱文件夹里有一封电子邮件往来，发件人和收件人包括我自己、每天给我化妆的肯尼斯·保罗，以及坐在肯尼斯·保罗旁边、坐在我旁边椅子上给我化妆的帕梅拉·桑托里。是的。哦，太棒了。
The three of us were clearly very interested in some cat videos. Uh-huh. So Pamela emailed Kenneth and I, the subject line says cat and sneakers, and the message says smart kitty exclamation point, enjoy. And it's a video Jenna and it was still in the email, so I'll put it in stories. It's a commercial for a foot odor spray and in the ad, the cat takes the owner's smelly sneakers and carries them one by one to its litter box and it had this ridiculous jingle. And after I rewatched it, it lived in my head for days.
我们三个显然对一些猫咪视频非常感兴趣。嗯哼。所以帕梅拉给肯尼斯和我发了一封邮件，主题行写着“猫和运动鞋”，正文中写道“聪明的猫咪叹号，请欣赏”。这是一个视频，詹娜，而且它还在邮件里，所以我会把它发到快讯故事里。这是一个关于脚臭喷雾的广告，在广告中，猫拿走了主人臭气熏天的运动鞋，一双一双地把它们叼到猫砂盆里，而且还有一个荒谬的叮咚旋律。在我重新看了之后，它在我脑海里挥之不去好几天。
So get ready for the jingle. Enjoy. So while that music is playing, the cat is moving the sneakers. I don't know if it's possible, maybe without the meows, but doesn't that music sound like the sneak music for the mom detectives? Like when we are sneaking up on a suspect. Yeah. Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, meow, meow, meow,
所以准备好迎接这个叮咚旋律吧。尽情享受吧。所以当音乐播放时，猫正在移动运动鞋。我不知道这是否可能，也许没有喵喵声，但这音乐听起来不就像妈妈侦探的潜行音乐吗？就像我们潜行接近嫌疑人时那样。对。喵，喵，喵，喵，喵，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，喵，喵，喵，
bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom. But maybe we say, mom, mom, mom, mom, detectives. Oh, who's going to watch the show? That is my digital clutter. I loved it. There was some hot emails going back and forth in hair and makeup. I think we should take a break. I want to show you something before we go.
咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚。但也许我们会说，妈妈，妈妈，妈妈，妈妈，侦探。哦，谁会看这个节目？这就是我的数字杂乱文件夹。我太喜欢了。发型和化妆间里来来往往的邮件真是火药味十足。我想我们该休息一下了。走之前我想给你看个东西。
Look what I have. Not going to show you what's written on them. You have two note cards. I have two note cards because I had two late-breaking ideas of things I wanted to share. One, the blue one, is full of facts. Great. These are late-breaking facts that came in from Randy Cordray, didn't have time to put them in my document, put them on a note card.
看我有什么。不给你们看上面写了什么。你有两张便签卡。我有两张便签卡，因为我突然有了两个最新想分享的想法。第一张，蓝色的，写满了事实。太棒了。这些是从兰迪·科德雷那里收到的最新事实，来不及放进我的文档里，所以写在便签卡上了。
The green note card is some personal stuff I want to share with you. It is completely unrelated to this episode, but I need to get it out. And you're seeing the need for a note card. Yep. Well, I'm excited to come back from this break because you have what I'm calling some hot facts because they're hot off the press. Hot off the press facts. And personal scoophage.
绿色便签卡是我想要和你们分享的一些个人事情。它和这一集完全无关，但我需要把它倾诉出来。你看出便签卡的必要性了吧。是的。好吧，我很兴奋从这个休息回来，因为你有所谓的劲爆事实，因为它们是刚出炉的新鲜事。刚出炉的事实。还有个人八卦。
Yep. We'll be right back. We are back, and you know who else is back, Pam and Jim. They are back from their honeymoon in Puerto Rico. And Kelly is really, really happy for them. She's really happy. I know. They have an adorable talking head.
对。我们马上回来。我们回来了，你知道谁也回来了吗，潘和吉姆。他们从波多黎各的蜜月旅行回来了。凯莉真的、真的很为他们高兴。她是真的很开心。我知道。他们有一个可爱的单人访谈。
The honeymoon is great. They're glowing. I mean, this was a great trip for them. But then, they're reminded of where they are now, which is with Michael and blind guy Mick Squeezy. I have a background catch in this scene. Is it at 58 seconds? No.
蜜月太棒了。他们满面春风。我的意思是，这对他们来说是一次伟大的旅行。但随后，他们被提醒他们现在在哪里，也就是和迈克尔以及盲人麦克·斯奎齐在一起。我在这个场景中抓到了一个背景彩蛋。是在58秒的时候吗？没有。
It starts at 36 seconds. Mindy's in the background behind White, like by those filing cabinets by the pillar. And she looks like she's clearly checking her phone. Her head is down. And then she looks up, and it's like she's like, oh crap, I'm supposed to be over there. And she does this slink move around the plant and scooches her way back up to where I think she's supposed to be. I filmed it.
从36秒开始。明迪在德怀特身后的背景里，就在那个柱子旁的档案柜旁边。她看起来明显在查手机。她低着头。然后她抬起头，好像在说，哦糟了，我应该去那边。然后她绕着植物做了一个鬼祟的动作，鬼鬼祟祟地挪回了我认为她应该在的地方。我拍下来了。
It's so hilarious. Oh my gosh. Are you serious? Yes. I have got to show it to you. I need you to see it in real time, lady. This is so funny. Look at this.
太搞笑了。哦天哪。你是认真的吗？是的。我必须给你看。女士，你需要实时看到这个。太搞笑了。看这个。
Oh my gosh. Her move around the tall plant is hilarious. Okay, well, at 58 seconds, I noticed Mindy is totally laughing in the background. Oh yeah. I caught that too. She starts to completely break. Mindy, very entertaining in the background of this scene. Yeah.
哦天哪。她绕过高大植物的动作太搞笑了。好吧，在58秒时，我注意到明迪在背景里笑得前仰后合。哦是的。我也注意到了。她开始彻底笑场了。明迪在这个场景的背景里非常搞笑。对。
The slink around the plant is amazing. Meredith is going to be the six-year-old in the office and ask Pam what they brought the office as a souvenir. Do you feel like Jim and Pam were obligated to bring gifts for their coworkers from their honeymoon? You know what? I don't think they were obligated, but I would. Like if I married a coworker in a small office and we went on a honeymoon, we would bring
绕过植物的动作太棒了。梅雷迪思要扮演办公室里六岁的小孩，问潘他们给办公室带了什么纪念品作为伴手礼。你觉得吉姆和潘有义务从他们的蜜月旅行中给同事带礼物吗？你知道吗？我觉得他们没有义务，但如果是我，我会带的。就像如果我在一个小办公室里和一个同事结婚，然后我们去度蜜月，我们会带回
something back. You just would. I thought the candies were perfect. That's sort of for the whole bullpen. I was surprised they brought an individual gift for Michael. They had two options. I know. Who was getting the seashell alarm clock, I wonder.
一些东西的。你肯定会的。我觉得糖果很完美。那算是给整个办公区大家的。我很惊讶他们给迈克尔带了一份单独的礼物。他们有两种选择。我知道。我在想是谁会拿到贝壳闹钟。
I don't know, but I would take it. That sounds really kitschy and fun to me. You would have kept that. You're not giving that away. I wouldn't give that away. I would have bought it for someone else, but then kept it for myself. Well, Meredith is bummed that Pam only brought candy. She's probably going to be even more bummed that it's going to take a while for Pam to
我不知道，但我会收下。这听起来对我很俗气很有趣。你会留着那个。你不会把它送人的。我不会送人的。我会给别人买，然后留给自己。好吧，梅雷迪思很沮丧潘只带了糖果。她可能会更沮丧，因为潘要花上一段时间才能把它摆出来，但我们一会儿就会讲到那儿。是的。
set it out, but we'll get there. Yeah. What's up with that? With the permission and the asking Michael, I was like, what is this weird power play happening over the candy? I don't know, but I thought it was so funny. So now the episode's going to start and Dwight is, um, well, he's starting his espionage. Yeah.
这是怎么回事？关于许可和询问迈克尔，我想，这到底是什么关于糖果的奇怪权力博弈？我不知道，但我当时觉得太搞笑了。所以现在这一集要开始了，而德怀特，嗯，他正在开始他的间谍活动。是的。
He storms into Jim's office and he's like two things. Number one, stop leaving your pens on my desk just because you got a promotion. It doesn't mean you get to leave your stuff all over the place. And number two, congratulations on your promotion. And he does this like turn and he's going to present him with a promotion gift of a wooden mallard. Well, Jim is going to say thanks for the duck and Dwight quickly says mallard. He corrects people multiple times in this episode when they say duck, he says mallard.
他冲进吉姆的办公室，说有两件事。第一，别再把你的笔丢在我的桌子上，仅仅因为你升职了并不意味着你可以把你的东西到处乱扔。第二，恭喜你升职。然后他做了一个转身，要送给他一个木质绿头鸭作为升职礼物。好吧，吉姆说谢谢这只鸭子，而德怀特迅速说这是绿头鸭。这一集里，当别人说鸭子时，他多次纠正他们，他说那是绿头鸭。
So Jenna, I had to know what's the difference between a duck and a mallard. Well, a mallard has a green head and it's a male duck. I know that from my summer's Lake of the Ozarks. We had lots of ducks. Here's what the internet says. Okay. There are over 120 species of ducks. A mallard is just one type of duck.
所以詹娜，我必须知道鸭子和绿头鸭有什么区别。好吧，绿头鸭有绿色的脑袋，是一只雄鸭。我从我在奥沙克湖的夏天知道了这一点。我们有很多鸭子。互联网是这么说的。好吧。有超过120种鸭子。绿头鸭只是一种鸭子。
Mallards are probably the most popular species of duck in North America and Eurasian wetlands, parks and ponds. This is a sexually demorphic species of duck. That means that the males and females look different from one another. Male mallards sport bright green heads and are easily identified, but female mallards are brown color, not without their own subtle beauty. Both males and females have a blue patch in their wing. Mallards make the popular quack sound that most people associate to the sound of a duck.
绿头鸭可能是北美和欧亚大陆湿地、公园和池塘中最受欢迎的鸭子种类。这是一种雌雄异形的鸭子。这意味着雄性和雌性看起来不一样。雄性绿头鸭有着亮绿色的脑袋，很容易辨认，但雌性绿头鸭是棕色的，也有其微妙的美丽。雄性和雌性的翅膀上都有一个蓝色的斑点。绿头鸭会发出大多数人联想到鸭子叫声的“嘎嘎”声。
And then it ended with this and a female mallard is particularly vocal. Oh, there you go. That's what the internet had to say about mallards. We had mallards at my parents' lake house. We loved them. Well, I'm not done. Oh, get ready for this. While googling mallards, guess what was the first thing that came up, which was crazy
然后以这句话结尾：雌性绿头鸭尤其多话。哦，原来如此。这就是互联网对绿头鸭的说法。我父母的湖边小屋有绿头鸭。我们很喜欢它们。好吧，我还没讲完。哦，准备好听这个。在谷歌搜索绿头鸭时，你猜弹出的第一件事是什么，这对我来说太疯狂了
to me? What? And I know you're going to think this is me having a thing for trains. But on July 3rd, 1938, a steam locomotive called the Mallard claimed the world speed record at 126 miles per hour. Oh, I think Google gave you that fact because it knows how much you like trains. I guess it does. I bet if I googled mallard, I would not get that.
什么？我知道你会觉得这是我对火车情有独钟。但在1938年7月3日，一辆名为“绿头鸭号”的蒸汽机车以每小时126英里的速度创造了世界速度纪录。哦，我觉得谷歌给你这个事实是因为它知道你有多喜欢火车。我想是的。我敢打赌，如果我谷歌搜索绿头鸭，我不会得到这个。
I'm going to do it right now. Okay. I'm curious. What did you google? I googled famous mallards. Famous mallards. I didn't know if there was like a popular story about a mallard. You know what comes up for me?
我现在就要搜一下。好的。我很好奇。你谷歌了什么？我谷歌了著名的绿头鸭。著名的绿头鸭。我不知道有没有关于绿头鸭的流行故事。你知道为我弹出了什么吗？
What? A Wikipedia page called List of Fictional Ducks. Ah, well, for me, this came up. It was named the mallard because Sir Herbert Nigel Gresley, hope I'm saying that right, was a British railway engineer who enjoyed breeding waterfowl as much as he loved making trains, I guess. He also designed a train he called the Flying Scotsman. And here's this.
什么？一个名为“虚构鸭子列表”的维基百科页面。啊，好吧，对我来说，弹出了这个。它被命名为“绿头鸭”是因为奈杰尔·格雷斯利爵士（Sir Herbert Nigel Gresley，希望我没发错音）是一位英国铁路工程师，他对培育水禽的喜爱不亚于他对制造火车的喜爱，我猜。他还设计了一辆他称之为“飞天苏格兰人”的火车。还有这个。
The A4 number 4468 Mallard still holds the record for being the fastest steam locomotive in the world. I'm going to get you a train. I just thought that was crazy. I was looking up information about mallards and I found a train. I think it's an algorithm in your computer now. It knows to show you these types of facts. I think you're going to get a lot of train facts.
A4型4468号“绿头鸭号”仍然保持着世界上最快蒸汽机车的纪录。我要给你买一辆火车。我只是觉得这太疯狂了。我在查关于绿头鸭的信息，结果找到了一辆火车。我想这是你电脑里的一个算法。它知道向你展示这些类型的事实。我觉得你会得到很多关于火车的冷知识。
I also got some wallpaper with ducks on it. You bought wallpaper with ducks? No, wallpaper came up in my search. If that tells you the other thing, I've been Googling, guys, I want a wallpaper. Listen, that's a subject for later. Can I have duck wallpaper or train wallpaper or both duck and train wallpaper? Okay. I'm going to stop talking.
我还找到了一些印有鸭子的壁纸。你买印有鸭子的壁纸了？不，壁纸出现在我的搜索中。如果这说明了另一件事的话，我一直在谷歌搜索，伙计们，我想要一张壁纸。听着，那是以后的话题。我能要鸭子壁纸、火车壁纸，还是鸭子和火车壁纸都要？好吧。我不说了。
I have an observation from the scene. What? So remember last week when we were talking about the storyline of Aaron destroying Pam's watercolor? Oh, yeah. Well, at one minute, 59 seconds over Dwight's shoulder. He's standing in Jim's office. You can see that there is nothing on the wall where Pam's watercolor should be.
我对这个场景有一个观察。什么？所以还记得上周我们谈到埃琳毁了潘的水彩画的故事线吗？哦，是的。好吧，在1分59秒德怀特的肩膀上方。他站在吉姆的办公室里。你可以看到潘的水彩画本该挂着的地方墙上一片空白。
And that is how it's going to be in this episode. The wall will be blank. There's another great shot of it at four minutes, 53 seconds, when Michael walks up to reception. But next week, there's going to be something there, not Pam's watercolor, but I'll point it out. Okay. So listen, ultimately, Jim is going to take the duck, Dwight leaves, he has a talking head where he reveals he inserted a listening device into the belly of the duck.
这一集里也会是这样。墙上会是空的。在4分53秒当迈克尔走到前台时，有一个绝佳的镜头展现了这一点。但下周，那里会挂上东西，不是潘的水彩画，但我会指出来的。好的。所以听着，最终，吉姆收下了那只鸭子，德怀特离开后，他有一个单人访谈，透露他在鸭子的肚子里塞了一个窃听器。
It looks like a walkie-talkie. It is. He calls it a listening device. This is a very crude system he's created. We'll find out why. Exactly. So something I want to point out, as Jim is sitting at his desk and he puts the mallard down, at two minutes, 50 seconds, there is a photo on Jim's desk of Pam.
它看起来像一个对讲机。是的。他称之为窃听器。这是他制造的一个非常简陋的系统。我们会发现原因的。完全正确。所以我想指出的一点是，当吉姆坐在办公桌前放下绿头鸭时，在2分50秒，吉姆的桌上有一张潘的照片。
Do you know what the photo is? No. It is that old, fuzzy-haired photo of Pam with her eyes half closed. It's the one they put the beans on. Oh my gosh. Why has he framed this weird picture of Pam and put it on his desk? It was so weird to me. It's weird.
你知道那是什么照片吗？不知道。那是那张老旧的、头发蓬松的、潘半闭着眼睛的照片。就是他们把豆子放在上面的那张。哦天哪。为什么他要把这张奇怪的潘的照片装进框里放在他的桌子上？我觉得太奇怪了。很奇怪。
I don't know. I don't know what that was about, but I'm going to track it because it's suddenly on his desk and I'm curious, is it going to stay there? How long will the fuzzy picture of Pam be on the desk? Tracking it. Tracking it. We have a delicious Jim and Michael scene coming up in the kitchen. Jenna, I just feel like you know you're in for a doozy of a conversation.
我不知道。我不知道那是怎么回事，但我会追踪它，因为它突然出现在他的桌子上，我很好奇，它会一直在那里吗？潘那张蓬松头发的照片会在桌上放多久？追踪它。追踪它。接下来我们在厨房里有一个精彩的吉姆和迈克尔的场景。詹娜，我只是觉得你知道你将面临一次艰难的对话。
If it starts with, I have recently taken a lover. Yeah. I mean, if you're leading in with that line, I'm going to get a cup of tea and sit down. I'm going to get comfortable. You know, Jim says, who's the lucky lady? John is totally breaking when he says that. Did you see? He's like, who's the lucky lady?
如果它是以“我最近找了个情人”开头的。是的。我的意思是，如果你用这句台词开场，我要去泡杯茶坐下来了。我要找个舒服的姿势。你知道，吉姆说，“谁是幸运的女士？”约翰在说这句话时完全笑场了。你看到了吗？他说，“谁是幸运的女士？”
Like that is John right there. And then I laughed so hard when Jim's like, you did not have sex with Pam's mom. And Michael's like, oh, big time. And Jim says, what kind of car does she drive? And Michael goes, a green Camry and Jim's like, oh yeah, that was not in the script. That curse that was on the day. Yeah. And then just everything about the beats of the scene is so funny.
就像那绝对是约翰本人。然后当吉姆说“你绝对没有和潘的妈妈上床”时，我笑得前仰后合。而迈克尔说“哦，大错特错”。吉姆说“她开什么车？”迈克尔说“一辆绿色的凯美瑞”，吉姆说“哦，是的”，这根本不在剧本里。那是当天现场发挥的。是的。然后这个场景节奏的方方面面都太搞笑了。
And when Jim is like, find a new way home, man. Oh, we got a fan question about that from Jessica S. in Columbia, South Carolina. She said in season two, episode two, Pam says that her mom lives about two hours away. But in this episode, Michael says it's easy to date Pam's mom because she's on his way home from work. Did Pam's mom move? Yes. We think she did after the divorce.
当吉姆说“换条路回家吧，老兄”。哦，我们收到了来自南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚市的杰西卡·S的粉丝提问。她说在第二季第二集里，潘说她妈妈住在两小时车程远的地方。但在这一集里，迈克尔说和潘的妈妈约会很方便，因为她在他的下班路上。潘的妈妈搬家了吗？是的。我们觉得她在离婚后搬家了。
Yeah, I believe that. Yeah. She moved closer to Pam. Michael is doing that thing. I feel like we've all done at some point where you date someone who's nearby because it's just easy. Yeah. But then when you break up, it's really a bummer.
是的，我相信是这样的。是的。她搬到离潘更近的地方了。迈克尔正在做我们觉得大家都在某个时候做过的事，那就是和一个附近的人约会，因为这样很简单。是的。但后来当你分手时，真的很令人沮丧。
It's really a bummer, guys, because then they're in your neighborhood. When I first moved to LA, there was a guy in my acting class. Yeah. And he lived up the street from me and we started dating, but it didn't last long. Oh, no. And then like, he was always there. It was so awkward. And you know what was really awkward?
伙计们，这真的很令人沮丧，因为他们就在你的街区里。我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我表演班里有个家伙。是的。他住在离我一条街的地方，我们开始约会了，但没持续多久。哦，不。然后就像，他总是晃悠。太尴尬了。你知道什么真的很尴尬吗？
Is that like near the tail end of it, you know, when the person's trying to get in touch with you, but you're not answering, he would say to me in class, he'd be like, hey, why didn't you answer the phone? I mean, I saw that you were home. And I'd be like, because this was like in the time of landlines when you called a person's home phone. In the dinosaur time. Yeah.
就是在快结束的时候，你知道的，当那个人试图联系你而你又不接电话时，他在班上对我说，“嘿，你为什么不接电话？我的意思是，我看到你在家了。”然后我会说，因为那是在打座机电话的年代，当你打别人家里的电话时。在恐龙时代。是的。
Yes. And I'd be like, oh, yeah, like I would go home and my phone would ring. And it was really weird. I mean, Sam, it's kind of like how Emily shouldn't have hooked up with Gabriel in her own building in Paris. I don't want to talk about this. You know, I don't want to talk about this. I've totally started watching Emily in Paris and it's making Sam crazy.
是的。然后我会说，“哦，是的，就像我回家了然后电话响了。”这真的很奇怪。我的意思是，萨姆，这有点像艾米丽不应该在巴黎她自己的大楼里跟加布里埃尔勾搭上。我不想谈这个。你知道，我不想谈这个。我完全开始看《艾米丽在巴黎》了，这把萨姆快逼疯了。
It's so bad. I'm sorry, but Gabriel is hot. I know one said he was. I don't. I mean, it would be hard to be his neighbor and not hook up with him. Right. Okay. I have not watched this show.
太糟糕了。我很抱歉，但加布里埃尔很帅。没人说他不帅。我不知道。我的意思是，成为他的邻居却不跟他勾搭上是很难的。好吧。我没看这个节目。
Do I need to watch it? Oh, Jenna. Yes. No, you don't. Yes. Watch it. It's just going to make you want to travel and eat like amazing food. But as a good person, not her.
我需要看吗？哦，詹娜。是的。不，你不需要。是的。看吧。它只会让你想去旅游并吃美味的食物。但作为一个好人，不要像她那样。
You guys know that the name of that show is supposed to be pronounced Emily and Perry. That was the intention. Well, that's not how she's going to pronounce it. Yeah. But she's in French class and it's she wouldn't pronounce it that way. Just us. Oh boy. I'm just saying I read an article.
你们知道那个节目的名字本意应该发音为“艾米丽在佩里”吗？那是原本的意图。好吧，她可不是这么发音的。是的。但她在上法语课，而且她不会那样发音。只有我们。哦，天哪。我只是说我读了一篇文章。
Wow. And the creators were like, you know, we thought it was a fun play on words. I can't get enough of it. I just watched her write off in a designer moped. Sam. Look. Yes. He's very hot.
哇。创作者们说，“你知道，我们觉得这是一个有趣的双关语。”我真是看不够。我刚刚看着她骑着设计师设计的轻便摩托车绝尘而去。萨姆。看。是的。他非常帅。
Her eyebrows are great. She is a quantifiably a bad person and this show makes me mad. Well, anyway, back in the kitchen, not in Paris, but in Scranton. I think we're learning an important lesson here. Don't date your co-worker's mom, but then Jim, Jim says, whatever you do, don't tell Pam. Yeah. Oh, Jim, you know, this is going to blow up in your face, buddy.
她的眉毛很棒。她确实是个糟糕透顶的人，这个节目让我抓狂。好吧，无论如何，回到厨房，不在巴黎，而在斯克兰顿。我觉得我们在这里学到了一个重要教训：不要和同事的妈妈约会，但接着吉姆，吉姆说，“无论如何，千万别告诉潘。”是的。哦，吉姆，你知道这会让你吃不了兜着走的，伙计。
Come on. It's true. Ever since Jim became a co-manager, I feel like he makes bad decisions. Are you saying he wasn't supposed to be co-manager? I'm just saying. Are you going on record? I'm saying he's like, I'm saying like maybe. You're having a hard time saying it, whatever it is you're trying to say.
拜托。确实如此。自从吉姆成为联合经理以来，我觉得他做出了很多糟糕的决定。你是说他不该当联合经理吗？我只是说说。你是要留下记录吗？我是说他好像在说，我是说也许。你很难把话说出口，不管你想说什么。
I'm saying that maybe, maybe this new job, he's actually working all day and it's causing him to not be able to dedicate all of his time to Pam. No. To have the same instincts he had before about like social dealings, you know, he blurts out that Pam is pregnant at the wedding and he puts beans on his co-worker's face. There's suddenly like, he doesn't have his good social instincts. You know what I think? What?
我是说也许，也许这份新工作，他其实整天都在工作，导致他无法全身心地投入到潘身上。不是的。没有保持他以前处理社交事务时的直觉，你知道的，他在婚礼上脱口而出潘怀孕了，还在同事的脸上贴豆子。突然之间，他失去了良好的社交直觉。你知道我在想什么吗？什么？
I think the more time you spend with Michael, the more you start becoming Michael-like. This is what I'm saying. Yes. Yes. Yes. Well, Michael is going to take Jim's advice. He's going to go up to Erin. He's going to change their dinner reservation from four people to two people and he says
我觉得你和迈克尔在一起的时间越多，你就会越来越像迈克尔。这就是我要说的。是的。是的。是的。好吧，迈克尔要听从吉姆的建议。他要去找埃琳。他要把他们的晚餐预订从四个人改成两个人，他说
it's okay to put out Pam's candy. Yay. There is a deleted scene where Erin announces to the bullpen, hey everyone, Jim and Pam brought candy and it is out now at front reception for you to enjoy. Like she makes this big announcement and Pam goes up to her and goes, you don't need to announce when candy is put out, just put it out. And then Kevin will come and take most of it and that's what happens. Oh.
可以把潘的糖果拿出来。耶。有一个被删减的场景是埃琳向办公区宣布，嘿大家，吉姆和潘带了糖果，现在已经放在前台供大家享用了。就像她发布了这个重大公告，然后潘走过去对她说，“当糖果摆出来时你不需要宣布，直接摆出来就行了。”然后凯文会来拿走大部分，事情就是这样。哦。
Well, I have a very exciting piece of news here. At four minutes and 54 seconds, we got a shot of Erin's desk and I would like to revisit something. Remember that boot and that bear on her desk and we could not figure out. What it meant? Yeah. Vinnie 2.022 tweeted us to say, I think I solved the pink mug at Erin's desk. It's from JFBB Ski Resort.
好吧，我这里有一个非常激动人心的消息。在4分54秒，我们得到了一个埃琳桌子的镜头，我想重新审视一件事。还记得她桌上那只靴子和那只熊吗，我们一直想不通
Oh, good catch Vinnie. Sure enough, the logo is the same. Makes sense that it's a ski boot and it stands for Jack Frost Big Boulder Ski Resort. It is located in Lake Harmony, Pennsylvania, which is only about 50 minutes outside of Scranton. It's not a big ski resort. Jack Frost Ski Mountain has about 18 runs. It has a freestyle area and a tubing area.
那是什么意思？是的。Vinnie 2.022在推特上对我们说，我想我解开了埃琳桌上粉色马克杯的谜团。它是来自JFBB滑雪度假村的。哦，好眼光，维尼。果不其然，标志是一样的。这合情合理，因为那是一只滑雪靴，它代表杰夫·弗罗斯特大博尔德滑雪度假村。它位于宾夕法尼亚州的哈莫尼湖，距离斯克兰顿大约只有50分钟车程。这不是一个很大的滑雪度假村。杰夫·弗罗斯特滑雪山大约有18条雪道。它有一个自由式区域和一个雪胎滑道区域。
Big Boulder has about 12 runs, a tubing run and a couple of freestyle terrain areas. But does this mean that Erin is a snow skier? Yeah, Erin's a skier. Who knew? Is this our only indication in the series that she skis? I think so. We don't know because we are doing this rewatch in real time. We might get mail that says, guys, in season eight, there's a huge storyline where Erin
大博尔德大约有12条雪道、一条雪胎雪道和几个自由式地形区域。但这是否意味着埃琳是个双板滑雪者？是的，埃琳是个滑雪者。谁能想到呢？这是我们在剧中唯一暗示她滑雪的地方吗？我想是的。我们不知道，因为我们是在实时重温。我们可能会收到邮件说，伙计们，第八季有一个庞大的故事线，埃琳
explains that she skis all the time. I feel like we would remember that. I feel like we would remember that she skis. I remember she roller skates. We don't have a big storyline about skiing. We don't know. Listen, I didn't remember that I used the big shredder. I made a big declaration that the shredder was never used and turns out that wasn't
解释说她一直在滑雪。我觉得我们会记得这一点。我觉得我们会记得她滑雪。我记得她滑轮滑。我们没有关于滑雪的大型故事线。我们不知道。听着，我不记得我用过那个大型碎纸机了。我曾信誓旦旦地宣称那台碎纸机从没被用过，结果证明那并不是
true. So you never know. You never know. But anyway, mystery solved. It's time to give Michael his gift. Pam is ready to march over there. Jim really doesn't want this to happen now. He is very worried that the whole Michael and the mom info is going to come out.
真的。所以你永远不知道。你永远不知道。不管怎样，谜团解开了。是时候给迈克尔送礼物了。潘准备走过去。吉姆现在真的很不想让这发生。他非常担心迈克尔和妈妈的信息会暴露。
They settle on the rum, they're going to give him rum. And as Jim's sleeping, what does he hear? That walkie talkie feedback that Dwight has duct taped underneath the mallard. Yeah, he's discovered the listening device, which Dwight intended for him to. But we don't know that yet. We don't know that yet. We don't. Well, I have a background catch in the next scene.
他们决定送朗姆酒。当吉姆在睡觉时，他听到了什么？那个德怀特用胶带粘在绿头鸭底部的对讲机回音。是的，他发现了窃听器，那是德怀特故意留给他的。但我们还不知道这一点。我们还不知道。我们不知道。好吧，我在下一个场景中抓到一个背景彩蛋。
Oh, spill it. As Michael is opening his box of rum on the side of the box, it says Oscuro rum, O-S-C-U-R-O rum. Yep. I looked it up. According to the Internet, that rum is actually from Barbados. Well, I was very curious about this rum as well. I could not find this anywhere.
哦，快说。当迈克尔在打开一盒朗姆酒时，在盒子的侧面，写着Oscuro朗姆酒，O-S-C-U-R-O朗姆酒。是的。我查过了。根据互联网的说法，那款朗姆酒实际上来自巴巴多斯。好吧，我对这款朗姆酒也很好奇。我到处都找不到。
I texted prop master Phil Shea. What Phil say? He made the whole thing. He made the bottle. He made the label. He made the box. He put the parrot on it, all of it. And it was scripted that there was a parrot hugging the bottle.
我给道具总监菲尔·谢伊发了短信。菲尔说什么？整个东西都是他制作的。他制作了瓶子。他制作了标签。他制作了盒子。他在上面放了一只鹦鹉，所有的东西。而且剧本里写着有一只鹦鹉抱着瓶子。
So when Jim has his line, Michael, keep the parrot. That was in the script. So Phil actually had to invent this whole prop. Isn't that amazing? There was also a line in the script that got cut when Jim and Pam are trying to decide which gift to give, either the seashell alarm clock or the rum, where Jim says whichever one doesn't look like we bought it at the airport. So that was another tip-off for Phil Shea.
所以当吉姆说出那句台词，迈克尔，留下这只鹦鹉。那是在剧本里的。所以菲尔实际上不得不凭空发明了这个道具。是不是太惊人了？剧本里还有一句台词被删掉了，当吉姆和潘试图决定送哪件礼物时，到底是贝壳闹钟还是朗姆酒，吉姆说无论哪一个看起来都不像我们在机场买的。所以那是给菲尔·谢伊的另一个暗示。
This had to look like something maybe you bought at the airport. Sure. Like in one of those souvenir shops. Yes. Well, I thought it looked great. Well, during this scene, Pam is going to find out what's going on. Because Aaron's going to come in and say, Michael, I changed your reservation. They're all set for two people.
这个必须看起来像你在机场买的东西。当然。就像在那些纪念品商店里一样。是的。好吧，我觉得它看起来很棒。好吧，在这个场景中，潘将弄清楚发生了什么。因为埃琳会走过来，说，迈克尔，我帮你改了预订。他们都为两个人准备好了。
And Pam is like, oh, fancy dinner tonight. Must be someone special. And Michael's like, it is. It actually, it really is. But I think it's going to end. Pam's like, why? No. Yeah.
然后潘说，哦，今晚有豪华晚餐。一定是很特别的人。迈克尔说，是的。实际上，确实如此。但我觉得它要结束了。潘说，为什么？不。是的。
Michael's like, Pam, it's very complicated. There's a lot of moving parts. And Pam's like, you know, if you really like this person, you should see where it goes. And Michael's like, you want me to be happy? John's face is Jim as he sees where this is going is so good. But then Jenna, your face, when you're like, who is it? Who is it, Michael? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, it was so good.
迈克尔说，潘，这非常复杂。有很多活动部件。潘说，你知道，如果你真的很喜欢这个人，你应该看看它会发展到哪一步。迈克尔说，你希望我幸福吗？约翰饰演的吉姆看到事情发展到这一步时的表情太棒了。但随后詹娜，你的表情，当你问，那是谁？是谁，迈克尔？不，不，不，不，不，不，演得太棒了。
It was really hard to shoot that scene. They wanted me to take a really long time to realize it. And then they wanted me, you know, to realize it, but be denying it inside. If I remember the direction correctly, it was like deeply deny this information, even though it's very clear to you who it is. It was so good. I thought you guys, that whole scene played out so great. Pam is going to leave the office and she's just going to go down to the parking lot and
拍那个场景真的很难。他们想让我花很长时间才意识到。然后他们想让我，你知道的，意识到这一点，但在内心深处极力否认。如果我没记错导演的要求的话，那就像是深深地否认这个信息，尽管你心里非常清楚那是谁。太棒了。我觉得你们整个场景演得太棒了。潘将离开办公室，直接走到停车场
scream. Just scream. There was a great deleted scene. Oh gosh. It's so cringy. It made Pam scream makes so much sense. Michael has Pam's mom's socks. That's all I'm going to say.
尖叫。放声尖叫。有一个很棒的被删减场景。哦天哪。太尴尬了。它让潘的尖叫变得非常合情合理。迈克尔拿着潘妈妈的袜子。这就是我要说的全部。
He found a pair of her socks and he's on the phone talking to her directly behind Pam's back while she's at her desk. You know, I've got something of yours. I do. You left them at my condo the other night. Yeah, I've got them right here. Mmm, they still smell like you. It's not gross.
他找到了她的一双袜子，在潘不知情的情况下，背着她在办公桌前直接给她打电话。你知道，我有你的一样东西。我有。你前天晚上把它们落在我的公寓里了。是的，我这就拿着呢。嗯，它们闻起来还像你。这并不恶心。
I like it. How much is it worth you? Oh, really? Oh, you are bad. You're very bad. I want to put them on your feet. I have them on my hands right now. Oh my God.
我喜欢。这值你多少钱？哦，真的吗？哦，你太坏了。你太坏了。我想把它们穿在你的脚上。我现在把它们套在我的手上呢。哦天哪。
And then it cuts to Pam screaming in the parking lot. Now, we're not sure if she's overheard this or not because his door was shut and it's over her shoulder, but still come on. This is what she would have to live with. Oh my gosh, I did not remember that scene. Oh, it is so cringy. He literally is smelling them. He puts them on his hands.
然后镜头切换到帕姆在停车场尖叫。现在，我们不确定她是否无意中听到了这个，因为他的门是关着的，而且镜头是从她肩膀上方拍的，但话虽如此，拜托。这就是她以后必须面对的生活。哦天哪，我不记得那个场景了。哦，太尴尬了。他真的在闻它们。他把它们戴在手上。
They're like these little like white footlet socks, you know, and they have like red and pink polka dots. Wow. Yeah, that's what Pam's reality would have been. With her screaming, it feels warranted. I am speechless. I really am. So I was going to notice that Michael seems tense, you know, and he's going to offer to
它们就像那种小小的白色船袜，你知道的，上面有红色和粉红色的圆点。哇。是的，这就是帕姆原本要面对的现实。伴随着她的尖叫，感觉这是合情合理的。我无言以对。我真的无言以对。所以本来我想注意到迈克尔看起来很紧张，你知道的，他要主动
give him the chills. This made me laugh so hard. So hard. So hard. Did everyone do this growing up? We did this growing up. This was a slumber party thing. You crack an egg on your head and let yolk run down.
让她感到背脊发凉。这把我笑得太厉害了。太厉害了。太厉害了。大家从小到大都玩过这个吗？我们小时候玩过。这是睡衣派对上的一个项目。你在自己头上敲个鸡蛋，让蛋黄流下来。
But I never did a knife in the back. We had two versions. We had one that started with X marks the spot with the dot, dot, dot, with the line, line, line, and a question mark. And then it was like, I think it was like you hit a rock on your head and you stabbed the knife in the back and then the spiders went up the arms. It always gave me the chills though. I mean, it's so violent.
但我从来没玩过背后插刀。我们有两个版本。其中一个是从“X”字标记开始，点、点、点，划线、线、线，还有一个问号。然后就好像是，我记得是好像你在头上敲块石头，然后在背上捅一把刀，接着蜘蛛就会爬上手臂。不过这总让我觉得背脊发凉。我的意思是，这太暴力了。
It's so violent. My gosh, we just did an egg crack on the head. We did egg crack. We did knife in the back, spiders up arms. Wow. I know. It definitely felt like a moment though from the 80s, right? This is like, you know, you grew up in the 80s moment.
太暴力了。天哪，我们刚才只是在头上敲个鸡蛋。我们玩过敲鸡蛋。我们玩过背后插刀，蜘蛛爬手臂。哇。我知道。不过这绝对有一种80年代的感觉，对吧？这就好像是，你知道的，你在80年代长大的那种时刻。
Yeah. Is this still happening today? Young people out there, do you still crack an egg on your head of your friend and then give them chills? What the yolk run down? I've done it to my daughter, but I do the egg on the head and the spades on her head. Oh, good. So Pam's going to yell at her mom now on the phone.
是的。现在这种事还在发生吗？外面的年轻人，你们现在还会在朋友头上敲鸡蛋，然后让他们背脊发凉吗？看着蛋黄流下来？我对我女儿做过，但我是在她头上敲鸡蛋，然后在她头上画蜘蛛。哦，很好。所以帕姆现在要在电话里对她妈妈大喊大叫了。
She's very upset. Jim's going to come out and sit with her on that little bench by the warehouse. It says in the script, he brings her hot chocolate and a jacket. Although I'd like to point out she was already wearing her jacket when she was screaming. Oh. So maybe she flung it off. I like to imagine that like in anger, she like flung her jacket across the parking lot and Jim had to come down and like gather it and bring it back to her.
她非常难过。吉姆走出来，和她一起坐在仓库旁边的那个小长椅上。剧本上写着，他给她带了热巧克力和一件夹克。虽然我想指出，她尖叫的时候其实已经穿着夹克了。哦。所以也许她把它甩掉了。我喜欢想象成她因为愤怒，把夹克甩过了整个停车场，然后吉姆不得不走过去把它捡起来还给她。
Well, now whenever I see us doing a scene on the side of the warehouse, I'm like, it's 3.30 because Randy told us that's when the lighting was good. I remember that hot chocolate was good. I thought it was a sweet thing that Jim brought hot chocolate. I know you can't really see me drinking it, but it actually was hot chocolate. They ask you, they say, what do you want in the cup? Would you like, you can have anything in it. We're not going to see it.
好吧，现在每当看到我们在仓库旁边拍戏时，我就会想，现在是3点30分，因为兰迪告诉过我们那是光线最好的时候。我记得那杯热巧克力很好喝。我觉得吉姆带热巧克力是一件很贴心的事。我知道你们其实看不到我在喝它，但它真的是热巧克力。他们会问你，他们说，你想在杯子里装什么？你想喝什么，里面什么都可以。反正我们又看不到。
You know. Yeah. We're not going to have iced tea. Well, it depended, you know, oftentimes I would put coffee in my coffee mug because then I could drink coffee, which was awesome. And this time I was like, you know what, hot chocolate sounds great. Can I have hot chocolate? And they said, sure.
你知道的。是的。我们总不能喝冰茶吧。嗯，这得看情况，你知道的，我经常在我的咖啡杯里装咖啡，因为那样我就可以喝咖啡了，这太棒了。而这次我说，你知道吗，热巧克力听起来不错。能给我来杯热巧克力吗？他们说，当然可以。
In addition to this hot chocolate, Jim is going to try to lighten Pam's mood. You know, he's going to try to gossip with her about the mallard. She does not care. She really doesn't care. She needs him to be more upset about this. This is his mother now, too. She says your mother is sleeping with Michael Scott. Oh, yeah.
除了这杯热巧克力，吉姆还要试图缓和帕姆的情绪。你知道的，他试图和她八卦那只绿头鸭的事。她一点不在乎。她是真的一点不在乎。她需要他对这件事感到更生气。这现在也是他的母亲了。她说你母亲在和迈克尔·斯科特睡觉。哦，是的。
And then she just walks away and lets him sit in that moment. And with that, I think we should take a break, but I want to point out, I have still not revealed what's on my two cards. Yeah. Will you get to it? I'm so curious. I'll get to it. It'll be in this next part.
然后她就走开了，留下他一个人坐在那里消化这个时刻。顺便，我觉得我们应该休息一下，但我得指出，我还是没有揭晓我那两张卡片上写的是什么。是的。你会说到这个吗？我太好奇了。我会说的。这会在下一部分讲到。
We'll be back. We are back, and Jenna, spill the beans on the green card and the blue card. Well, the blue card is first up, Angela. We're in the scene where Jim asks Andy to come in his office. He's going to start blasting some opera music. And of course, this is driving Dwight crazy. The aria that Jim is playing is from a German opera called Martha by Friedrich von Flotto. It is a romantic comedy opera, lady.
我们马上回来。欢迎回来，安吉拉，快把绿卡和蓝卡上的秘密都抖出来吧。好的，安吉拉，先说蓝卡。我们在吉姆叫安迪进他办公室的那场戏里。他开始放劲爆的歌剧音乐。当然，这把德怀特快逼疯了。吉姆在放的咏叹调出自弗里德里希·冯·弗托创作的一部名为《玛莎》的德国歌剧。这是一部浪漫喜剧歌剧，女士。
Everyone in the office is hearing it, and Creed starts crying. Oh, I had so many background catches as we went around the room. At 9 minutes 40 seconds, the camera zooms in on you, Angela, listening to the opera, and the whiteboard over your shoulder says this. I loved it. It says, Post it Rep Joe, 4 p.m. with Phyllis. A Post it Rep is coming in to talk to Phyllis, Angela. And then at 9 minutes 45 seconds, when the camera shows that Creed is crying, I noticed
办公室里的每个人都听到了，克里德开始哭泣。哦，我们在屋里走动时，我捕捉到了好多背景细节。在9分40秒时，镜头特写了你，安吉拉，正在听歌剧，你肩膀后面的白板上写着这个。我很喜欢。上面写着：“邮便贴纸代表乔，下午4点与菲利斯见面。”一个邮便贴纸代表要来和菲利斯谈事情，安吉拉。然后在9分45秒时，当镜头拍到克里德在哭时，我注意到
that Creed has a photo of himself taped to the wall. A headshot of himself. Not even in a frame, just taped to the wall. Just taped to the wall. Freestyle. That tracks. But here's what I'm going to tell you. Here's the late breaking info that came in from Randy Cordray.
克里德把一张自己的照片粘在了墙上。他自己的大头照。甚至连相框都没有，就直接用胶带粘在墙上。就用胶带粘在墙上。太随意了。这很符合他的作风。但我要告诉你的是。这是兰迪·科德雷刚发来的最新爆料。
It's about that song that Jim is playing. He said that that song was public domain. However, we had to pay $1,500 in royalty rights to play that particular recording. What if you don't think about stuff I don't think about when I watch a show? Nope. I do now, though. Well, now Michael is going to hold a meeting in the conference room. A lot happens in this meeting.
关于吉姆正在放的那首歌。他说那首歌是公共版权。然而，为了播放那个特定的录音版本，我们不得不支付了1500美元的版税。当你看了节目之后，你会不会去想那些我根本不会去想的事情？不会。不过我现在会了。好吧，接下来迈克尔要在会议室开个会。这次会议发生了好多事。
And yet I titled this scene, Ryan has a hat. Uh-huh. I wrote down at 10 minutes 35 seconds, we see Ryan's fedora for the first time. Out of the blue. No explanation. Out of the blue. What's going on? This conference room meeting is actually going to be about the fact that corporate wants
然而我给这场戏起的名字是：瑞安戴了顶帽子。嗯哼。我在10分35秒时记下了，我们第一次看到瑞安的费多拉帽。毫无征兆。没有任何解释。毫无征兆。怎么回事？这次会议实际上是关于公司希望
each branch to brainstorm ways to better communicate with their community. And whoever comes up with the best idea is going to get a $50 gift certificate to a local restaurant. I want to point out when Jim announces the $50 gift certificate, how happy everyone was. There's a reaction shot pass. And we're all like, even Angela Martin is like, oh, that's nice. Good incentive. Everyone likes food.
每个分公司都集思广益，想出与社区更好地沟通的方法。谁能想出最好的点子，就能获得一张当地餐厅的50美元礼品卡。我想指出的是，当吉姆宣布50美元的礼品卡时，大家有多么高兴。有一个大家的反应镜头。我们都觉得，甚至连安吉拉·马丁都觉得，哦，那挺好的。很好的奖励。每个人都喜欢食物。
People are shouting out ideas, but Pam is going to suggest that Michael leaving Scranton would make Scranton a better place. That would help the community. Oh, Pam's turning up the heat. She literally starts chanting, no more meetings and stands up like waving her hands about, no more meetings. Yes, we had a fan question from Zach M in Venice Center, New York in the conference room scene.
大家都在大喊大叫地提建议，但帕姆却暗示迈克尔离开斯克兰顿会让斯克兰顿变得更好。那会对社区有帮助。哦，帕姆开始火上浇油了。她甚至开始喊起“不要再开会了”，并站起来挥舞着双手喊着“不要再开会了”。是的，我们在会议室的那场戏里收到了来自纽约州威尼斯中心的扎克·M的粉丝提问。
Was it Leslie David Baker's idea to join in with Pam's no more meetings? Or was that in the script? I also just love his reaction when Michael says, I'm sensual. Oh, yeah. Stanley is the king of facial sass. I loved the term facial sass. Yeah, me too. You know what?
是莱斯利·大卫·贝克的的主意要加入帕姆的“不要再开会了”口号中吗？还是那是剧本里写好的？我也超级喜欢当迈克尔说“我很性感”时他的反应。哦，是的。斯坦利是面部表情吐槽之王。我太喜欢“面部表情吐槽”这个词了。是的，我也是。你知道吗？
Guys, that was all Leslie. It was not scripted that anyone should join in with Pam, but he made the choice to be delighted. And I absolutely love it. During Pam's rally cry to get meetings canceled, Michael gets a phone call and he starts to take it. This was the moment my character decides to raise her hand and participate. And Jim's like, yes, Angela, you should tell us your ideas. And I go off into my speech about the accounting department.
伙计们，那全都是莱斯利即兴发挥的。剧本里并没有写任何人应该加入帕姆的口号，但他做出了展现喜悦的决定。我绝对爱死这个了。在帕姆号召大家取消会议期间，迈克尔接到了一个电话，他开始接听。这就是我的角色决定举手参与的时刻。吉姆说，是的，安吉拉，你应该把你的想法告诉我们。于是我发表了一大段关于会计部门的演讲。
And the rest of the room, they don't give a crap about what Angela is saying. They want to hear Michael's phone call because he starts it off and he's saying, no, no one talks to my baby that way. Yeah, yeah, no, I'll talk to her. This is all anyone wants to hear. For sure. It was really hard for me to do those lines so seriously because we were all cracking up.
而房间里的其他人，他们根本不在乎安吉拉在说什么。他们只想听迈克尔的电话，因为他一接起来就在说：“不，没人能那样跟我宝贝说话。对，对，不，我来跟她谈。”这就是所有人唯一想听的。确实如此。我要把那些台词演得那么严肃真的很困难，因为我们都在狂笑。
Steve was being so funny and I checked the script. Everything he's saying was totally scripted. All of that. It was perfect. It was perfect. The only line that I caught that was improvised was actually by Brian Baumgartner because when Michael comes back in the room, Kevin says, who's Pickle? Yes.
史蒂夫表现得太搞笑了，我查了剧本。他说的所有话完全都是剧本里写好的。全部都是。太完美了。太完美了。我发现的唯一一句即兴台词其实是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳说的，因为当迈克尔回到房间时，凯文说：“谁是小黄瓜？”是的。
And that was not in the script. Yes. And that made us laugh too. I don't know if you noticed when Michael's phone rang. It had a distinct ringtone. I couldn't put my finger on it though. Did you pick it up? I played it over and over and over again.
而那并不是剧本里的。是的。这也把我们逗笑了。我不知道你们有没有注意到迈克尔的电话响的时候。它有一个独特的铃声。不过我一时想不起那是哪首歌了。你注意到了吗？我把它反复听了又听、听了又听。
I just noticed that it wasn't like a standard ringtone. And Michael is known for having special songs on his phone. Right. So maybe this ringtone was assigned to Pam's mom for a reason. I couldn't figure it out. But in the script, it says that Michael's cell phone ring is supposed to be the song Sexual Healing. This brings me back to the blue card.
我只是注意到它不像标准的铃声。而且迈克尔以手机里有特殊歌曲而闻名。对吧。所以也许这个铃声是专门为帕姆的妈妈设置的，是有原因的。我想不出来。但在剧本中，迈克尔的手机铃声应该是那首《Sexual Healing》。这让我想起了那张蓝卡。
Sure enough, we did pay to have his ringtone be Sexual Healing. That is what is playing. We paid $26,500 just for that ringtone. Whoa. Which I'm sad to say, the joke didn't even land when I heard it. Someone must have caught it. Out there in the world, someone caught it. But yeah, that ringtone also is only like six seconds?
果不其然，我们确实付了钱把他的铃声设为《Sexual Healing》。播放的就是那个。我们仅仅为了那个铃声就付了26500美元。哇。而让我感到难过的是，当我听到这个笑话时，它甚至都没有戳中笑点。肯定有人注意到了。在世界的某个角落，有人注意到了。但是，是的，那个铃声也只有大约六秒钟？
If that, yes. Well, after Michael's phone call, everyone's going to learn that he's dating Pam's mom and they're like, Michael, you're out of line. And then Michael makes this impassioned speech. You know, like, why can't I have love? You know? Yeah. And then Phyllis is like, well, Michael, I wish you luck.
如果真有那么长的话，是的。好吧，在迈克尔的电话之后，所有人都知道了他在和帕姆的妈妈约会，他们就说，迈克尔，你太过分了。然后迈克尔发表了一番充满激情的演讲。你知道的，比如，为什么我不能拥有爱情？你知道吗？是的。然后菲利斯说，好吧，迈克尔，祝你好运。
And then Oscar starts to chime in and Pam is like, shut up, Oscar. This really starts a battle between Michael and Pam. Yeah. You know, everyone's on Pam's side, but they quickly turn to Michael's side. And this is even more frustrating for Pam. The news comes out, she thinks she's going to have backup and she doesn't. I mean, even to the point where when she walks up to accounting, Angela gives her a little sarcastic sass.
接着奥斯卡也开始插话，帕姆就说，闭嘴，奥斯卡。这真的引发了迈克尔和帕姆之间的一场大战。是的。你知道的，每个人都站在帕姆这边，但他们很快又倒向了迈克尔那边。这让帕姆更加沮丧。消息传出去时，她以为自己会有后援，结果却没有。我的意思是，甚至当她走到会计部时，安吉拉还给了她一点尖酸刻薄的讽刺。
Angela's enjoying this. Are you kidding? Angela's about to bust out some popcorn. Well, lady, we got fan mail from Jamie in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, who said, Angela, your delivery of Pam, how's your day going? Is my all time favorite line in the entire series? What? It is absolutely perfect and hilarious.
安吉拉正幸灾乐祸呢。开什么玩笑？安吉拉正准备掏爆米花呢。好吧，女士，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的杰米的粉丝来信，他说：“安吉拉，你那句‘帕姆，你今天过得怎么样？’的台词演绎是我整个系列中最最喜欢的台词！”什么？绝对完美又搞笑。
Thank you. Jamie, I think we might need to send you an Angela sass sweatshirt. Oh, we should. You like yourself some Angela sass. We're going to figure out how to get that to you. Thank you, Jamie. It was very fun to play something other than angry. And so being that like passive aggressive bitch was delicious.
谢谢你。杰米，我觉得我们可能需要给你寄一件安吉拉式吐槽卫衣。哦，我们应该这么做。你还挺喜欢你身上的安吉拉式刻薄劲的。我们会想办法把它寄给你的。谢谢你，杰米。能演一些不是生气的情绪真的很有趣。所以那种被动攻击型的碧池做派简直太带劲了。
Well Pam and Michael have clearly drawn a line in the sand. She wants him to leave the office. He's like, I'm willing to die here. She's like, I'm willing to die here. And there's a standoff. There was an amazing deleted runner between Michael and Jim, where Michael is pleading to Jim to please help him with Pam. It starts in the kitchen.
好吧，帕姆和迈克尔显然已经在沙地上画了一条分界线。她希望他离开办公室。他却说：“我宁愿死在这里。”她则说：“我我也宁愿死在这里。”双方陷入了僵局。迈克尔和吉姆之间本来有一段非常精彩的被删掉的对手戏，在这段戏里，迈克尔恳求吉姆帮帮他，去对付帕姆。戏是从厨房开始的。
I want you to hear part of it. I need you to side with me on this. You're the boss. Everybody here considers you to be the boss more than me. That's crazy. Because you've been the boss way longer, so you've dealt with situations just like this dozens of times. I think that you can solve this because I am not that smart.
我想让你听听其中的一部分。我需要你在这件事上支持我。你是老板。这里的每个人都认为你比我更像是老板。这太疯狂了。因为你当老板的时间长得多，所以你处理过几十次像这样完全相同的状况。我觉得你能解决这个问题，因为我没有那么聪明。
Toilet guard, golden ticket, you're a creative mastermind. You have a relationship with Pam. You know her better than I do. Michael, you know Pam way better than I do. That's only partially true. So then the scene somehow becomes this, who's the best boss off? Because whoever's the better boss is who has to go handle Pam. I am an idiot.
厕所卫士、金奖券，你是个创意大师。你跟帕姆有交情。你比我更了解她。迈克尔，你比我了解帕姆得多。那只是一部分事实。所以然后这场戏不知怎么就变成了这样一场比赛：“谁才是最好的老板”？因为谁是更好的老板，谁就得去应付帕姆。我真是个白痴。
You're brilliant, man. You know it. I wouldn't even know where to start, Michael. You are an excellent moderator, boss, friend. You are the greatest light of hand magician I've ever seen. You're the man for the job. That's why you were promoted. I can't lie anymore.
你才是个天才，老兄。你心里清楚。我甚至都不知道该从哪里下手，迈克尔。你是一位杰出的主持人、老板、朋友。你是我见过最伟大的幻术魔术师。你就是干这活儿的不二人选。这就是为什么你得到了晋升。我再也不能撒谎了。
You're a genius. Well, okay, all right. That just made me laugh. I guess Michael's going to end up going to Toby. Yeah, because he went to Jim and it didn't work. He won the best boss off and he doesn't want to deal with Pam. So he is now having to choose his last resort. He gives Toby a hug.
你简直是个天才。好吧，行，好吧。这真的把我逗笑了。我想迈克尔最后还是要去找托比。是的，因为他找了吉姆，但行不通。他赢得了“最佳老板”的称号，而他又不想应付帕姆。所以他现在不得不选择他最后的退路。他给了托比一个拥抱。
There were so many moments in the scene that I thought were just perfection. First of all, when he goes to sit down and Toby's like, I can get you a chair or you can sit on the shredder. Okay. Yeah. And also Toby's talking head where he is like, he always knew that he and Michael would become friends. Yeah.
这场戏里有太多我觉得简直完美的时刻了。首先，当他走过去坐下时，托比说：“我可以给你搬把椅子，或者你可以坐在碎纸机上。”好吧。是的。还有托比的访谈镜头，他说他一直都知道他能和迈克尔成为朋友。是的。
If Michael could just give him a chance, you know. Oh my gosh. Heartbreaking. I also think that Toby is very excited to have a reason to go talk to Pam, but it does not go well. And no. At all. And Michael immediately turns on Toby.
只要迈克尔肯给他一个机会，你知道的。哦天哪。太心碎了。我也觉得托比非常高兴能有一个理由去找帕姆说话，但事情进展得并不顺利。而且并没有。一点也不。而且迈克尔立刻就对托比翻脸了。
Oh, by the way, lady, we skipped over a very important scene over in Kelly's nook. Yes. The fedora moment because Dwight is all of a sudden hearing a conversation between Kelly and Ryan through the mallard walkie-talkie. We can hear Kelly talking about Ryan's fedora. She wants to get one. Where did he get his? She asks.
哦，对了，女士，我们漏掉了一个非常重要的场景，就在凯利的角落。是的。费多拉帽的那个时刻，因为德怀特突然通过绿头鸭对讲机听到了凯利和瑞安之间的谈话。我们听到凯利在谈论瑞安的费多拉帽。她想弄一顶。她问他是在哪儿买的？
He says, I'd rather not say. Yeah. He doesn't want to get into it. No. All the while Dwight is running back to Kelly's nook and sees the mallard on her desk. A gift from Jim. And once again, Dwight is like, where did you get that mallard? Kelly's like, what the hell is a mallard?
他说：“我不想说。”是的。他不想深入讨论这个。不。与此同时，德怀特一路小跑回凯利的小角落，看到了她桌上的绿头鸭。那是吉姆送的礼物。德怀特又一次问道：“你从哪儿弄来的这只绿头鸭？”凯利说：“绿头鸭到底是个什么鬼？”
Oh, Professor Damian D Duck. Yeah. I want to say that we got some fan mail from Curie C in North Hollywood, California, who pointed out that Ryan is not wearing a fedora. He is wearing a trilby. It's a different kind of hat. I looked this up, the main difference between these two hats, they're shaped very similarly, but it's the size of the brim.
哦，达米安·D·达克教授。是的。我想说的是，我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州北好莱坞的居里·C的粉丝来信，她指出瑞安戴的根本不是费多拉帽。他戴的是蒂资帽（trilby）。那是另一种帽子。我查了一下，这两种帽子的主要区别在于，它们的形状非常相似，但帽檐的大小不同。
Curie noted that trilbies were very popular during this time, but they were often misidentified as fedoras. This trend was often found with, quote, gents like Ryan, who had a tendency to condescendingly explain things to other, even though the information was not accurate. This moment just is so peak, Ryan, that Ryan would be walking around wearing a trilby but calling it a fedora. I do vaguely remember that like, I feel like Brad Pitt used to wear these or something. Like I feel like I remember seeing like big celebrities wearing these hats.
居里指出，蒂资帽在当时非常受欢迎，但它们经常被误认为是费多拉帽。这种潮流往往出现在诸如“像瑞安这样喜欢以居高临下的态度向别人解释事情的绅士们”身上，尽管那些信息并不准确。这个时刻简直是太典型的“瑞安风格”了，瑞安居然会戴着一顶蒂资帽到处晃悠，却非要叫它费多拉帽。我隐约记得，我觉得布拉德·皮特以前好像戴过这种帽子之类的。就好像我记得看到过大明星们戴过这种帽子。
Oh yeah, it was like, like a mini moment. It was a moment. These trilby hats on the gents, the hipster gents. The hipsters. Lady, we're getting near the end of this episode, and I'd like to get out my green index card. Oh, this is the personal stuff. This is personal, totally unrelated to the episode. Here's what it is.
哦，是的，这就好像是一种，小小的流行趋势。它曾经流行过一阵子。这些绅士们戴着的蒂资帽，文艺青年绅士们。文艺青年。女士，我们快接近这一集的尾声了，我想拿出我的绿色索引卡。哦，这是个人私事。这是私事，跟这一集完全无关。内容是这样的。
Lady, you and I have been working really hard producing the podcast each week. We've been doing the final, final pass of our book. Oh my gosh, the book. The book. We talk constantly, but we talk about work. We have not had a good BFF download in a few weeks, and to me, that feels like very long time not to have a BFF download with you. I know.
女士，你和我每周都在非常努力地制作播客。我们一直在对我们的书进行最后一遍又一遍的校对。哦天哪，那本书。那本书。我们一直在聊天，但我们聊的都是工作。我们已经好几周没有好好地进行一次闺蜜连线私聊了，对我来说，感觉已经过了好久没有和你进行闺蜜私聊了。我知道。
We used to at least once a week be able to grab lunch or breakfast or go for a walk or sit on one of our porches and just have just like a gal pal gab. I have three things that I have been wanting to talk to you about, but I've not had the chance because every time we're talking, it's about work. Are we going to do it right here? This is my moment. I need this moment. Okay.
我们以前每周至少能有一次一起吃个午饭或早饭，或者去散散步，或者坐在我们其中一人的门廊上，像好姐妹一样八卦聊天。我有三件事一直想跟你聊聊，但一直没机会，因为每次我们聊天，内容都是关于工作的。我们现在就要在这里聊吗？这就是我的时刻。我需要这个时刻。好吧。
And I'm just going to let everybody in on the types of things that I would bring up to you in a BFF download. Are you ready? I wrote them on the card because I actually been writing them down so I don't forget to tell you. Yes. I'm so excited. I didn't see this coming today.
而且我要让所有人都知道我会跟你聊些什么样的话题，在我们闺蜜连线私聊的时候。准备好了吗？我把它们写在卡片上了，因为我其实一直有把它们写下来，这样我就不会忘记告诉你了。太棒了。我今天完全没料到会有这出。
I know. But this was my in. So the first one is something that has been bothering me for a really, really long time. And I have strong feelings about it. I need to get it off my chest and I don't want people to come for me. Oh no. Okay. Okay.
我知道。但这就是我的契机。所以第一件事是一件困扰了我非常非常久的事情。我对它有着强烈的感受。我需要把它一吐为快，我希望大家不要喷我。哦不。好吧。好吧。
But you're my BFF and I can say this to you. Okay. What the f*** is up with sun butter? It is so gross. It tastes horrible. Who is eating it? Who is eating sunflower butter? Who?
但你是我的闺蜜，我可以对你直说。好吧。葵花籽黄油（sun butter）到底是个什么鬼东西？它太恶心了。味道太可怕了。到底是谁在吃它？谁在吃葵花籽黄油？谁？
So this is the first I've never hearing of sun butter because you know I love just butter butter. No. Sunflower butter is like... Is that fake butter? It's a peanut butter alternate, okay? You know, you've got almond butter, cashew butter, all these butters that are made out of tree nuts and nuts and seeds and they have made a spread out of sunflower seeds.
所以这是我第一次听说葵花籽黄油，因为你知道我只喜欢真正的黄油。不。葵花籽黄油就像是……那是假黄油吗？它是花生黄油的替代品，好吗？你知道的，你有杏仁黄油、腰果黄油，所有这些由树坚果、坚果和种子做成的黄油，他们用葵花籽做成了一种抹酱。
And Angela, it's gross. It is not good. And I just need to know is anyone like buying it for a second time? Because you'll buy it and be like, oh, sunflower butter. This might be really delicious. Let me eat it. Does anyone buy it for a second time? Anyone?
而且，安吉拉，它很恶心。一点也不好吃。我只是想知道到底有没有人会买第二次？因为你会买它然后觉得，哦，葵花籽黄油。这可能会很好吃。让我尝尝。有人会买第二次吗？有人吗？
Cassie, Sam, feel free to weigh in on this. Your feelings on sunflower butter. I've never heard of sunflower butter. Thank you, Cassie. Thank you. I have no idea this exists. God, three of us had never heard of it. Guys, don't buy it, okay?
卡西、萨姆，欢迎随时发表你们的看法。你们对葵花籽黄油有什么感觉。我从来没听说过葵花籽黄油。谢谢你，卡西。谢谢你。我完全不知道这东西存在。天哪，我们三个都没听说过。伙计们，别买它，好吗？
My God, the sun butter people are coming for you. I know. And listen, I know that this can be an alternate for people who have peanut allergies. I just want to say I'm so sorry that this is your alternate. I'm sorry. It tastes horrible. I will say, even though I didn't know it exists, this absolutely sounds like something Emily in Paris would eat.
天哪，葵花籽黄油的人要来找你算账了。我知道。而且听着，我知道这对那些花生过敏的人来说可以是一个替代品。我只想说，我很遗憾这是你们的替代品。我很抱歉。它味道太可怕了。我要说的是，虽然我之前不知道它的存在，但听起来这绝对是《艾米丽在巴黎》会吃的东西。
Oh, yeah. You know what, Sam? Every morning. She would be bummed because she couldn't get her order of sun butter from the states. Exactly. And she would probably go into work at Savoir and be like, oh, my sun butter hasn't arrived. And they'd be like, oh, this stupid American. All right.
哦，是的。你知道吗，萨姆？她每天都会吃。她会因为买不到从美国进口的葵花籽黄油而沮丧。一点没错。而且她大概会去希尔（Savoir）上班，然后说：“哦，我的葵花籽黄油还没到。”然后他们就会说：“哦，这个愚蠢的美国人。”好啦。
Well, sorry. Sorry, Emily in Paris tangent. That's all right. All right. I've been meaning to complain to you about it ever since I tried it and I tried it like three weeks ago. Done. My second thing.
好吧，抱歉。抱歉扯到《艾米丽在巴黎》了。没关系。好啦。自从我尝试过它之后，我一直想跟你吐槽它，而我大概是在三周前尝试的。说完了。我的第二件事。
Okay. Gluten-free Oreos are amazing. You cannot tell the difference. I love them. They are so good. Thank you Oreos for making gluten-free Oreos. Jenna, are all your things food related? They are.
好吧。无麸质奥利奥太神奇了。你根本吃不出区别。我太爱它们了。它们太好吃了。谢谢奥利奥生产了无麸质奥利奥。珍娜，你所有的事都跟食物有关吗？是的。
Okay. They are. Does that surprise you? The only thing that's funny to me is if we were in person, I know you and you would have made me A, eat the Oreo because I'd be like, no, I don't want it. I don't want it. I don't like it. And then you might make me try the sun butter.
好吧。是的。这让你感到惊讶吗？唯一让我觉得好笑的是，如果我们是在现实中面对面，我了解你，你肯定会让我——A，吃下那个奥利奥，因为我会说：“不，我不要。我不要。我不喜欢。”然后你可能还会逼我尝尝葵花籽黄油。
Oh, yeah. Okay. Here's the last thing. I recently started following Jessica Seinfeld on Instagram. Oh, yeah. I've been following her for a while and she does all these vegan recipes. Yes. Every day she posts herself making a vegan recipe from her cookbook, which is called
哦，是的。好吧，最后一件事情。我最近开始在Instagram上关注杰西卡·宋飞。哦，是的。我关注她有一段时间了，她做了所有这些纯素食谱。是的。她每天都会发自己从她的食谱书里做一道纯素食谱的视频，那本书叫作
Vegan at Times. Yeah. The videos are so compelling. Everything she's making looks so delicious. She always looks so fashionable too and her kitchen's so tidy. I love these videos so much. Every day I look forward to them. What is she making today?
《有时吃纯素》。是的。那些视频太吸引人了。她做的每一样东西看起来都那么美味。她总是看起来那么时髦，而且她的厨房也那么整洁。我太喜欢这些视频了。我每天都满怀期待。她今天在做什么？
Oh, she's frying some tofu today. Oh, she's making like a pesto out of spinach. Yeah. I want to get the cookbook and try some of these vegan dishes. It's making me want to eat vegan. That's it, lady. That was it. That was my BFF download.
哦，她今天在煎豆腐。哦，她在用菠菜做某种青酱。是的。我想买那本食谱书，然后尝试做一些这些纯素菜肴。这让我有种想吃纯素的冲动。就是这样，女士。这就是全部了。这就是我的闺蜜连线私聊。
Is there anything that you want to share? Anything you've been needing to tell me? I think my big thing I would tell you is I am losing my mind at the amount of stacks of clutter in my house right now. It's like when you walk in the door, there's like a pile of shoes and the kids have wedged some socks in their shoes that have been forgotten about. And then there's like an arts and craft project that never got fully put away, but it's just sort of stacked tidily on the dining table.
有什么你想分享的吗？有什么你一直想跟我说的吗？我觉得我要告诉你的最大一件事是，我现在对我家里的杂物堆的数量感到抓狂。就好像你一进门，就有一堆鞋子，孩子们还在鞋子里塞了一些早就被遗忘的袜子。然后还有一些艺术手工艺品项目，从来没有被完全收好，只是整齐地堆在餐桌上。
I don't know, Jenna. I'm having to walk through my house and go into my happy place of like, I'm going to get to that. I'm going to get to that pile. I'm going to get to that pile. It's all going to be okay. Yeah. You know, I can really relate to that because when we get into these like heavy work periods
我不知道，珍娜。我不得不穿过我的房子，进入我那快乐的小世界，心里想着：“我会去收拾的。我会去收拾那一堆的。我会去收拾那一堆的。一切都会好起来的。”是的。你知道吗，我真的对此深有感触，因为当我们进入这种繁重的工作期时——
that we go through from time to time, I feel like I have to shut all of that out. And then when we're done, I know when we turn in this pass of the book, all that stuff is going to come into focus for me and it's going to be super overwhelming. Like all the piles that right now I'm managing to compartmentalize out of my life are going to come into sharp focus and they're going to bother me very much and I'm going to have to spend two days cleaning. I would love like a week at home, like a staycation where we have no plans and every day I tackle one little nook.
我们时不时就会经历的那种时期，我觉得我不得不把所有这些杂乱都屏蔽掉。然后等我们忙完了，我知道当我们交出这一版校稿时，所有这些东西都会重新进入我的视线，这会让我超级不知所措。就像那些我现在还能设法从生活中隔离开来的杂物堆，到时候会清晰地映入眼帘，它们会让我非常烦恼，我将不得不花两天时间来打扫。我真希望能在家里待上一周，就像是一次宅度假，我们没有任何计划，每天我只对付一个小角落。
Like we have this area like under our stairs that is a absolute hot effin mess. Lady, I really liked that hearing all that stuff. I hope everyone listening to the podcast enjoyed that. I feel like if I go in the grocery store and see sun butter, I'm going to like have some reaction. I'm going to be like, huh, sorry, just for you. I've been holding that in so long and anyway, and if I finally tidy under the stairs, I'll share on social about it.
就像我们楼梯底下有个区域，那绝对是一个一团糟的烂摊子。女士，我真的很喜欢听你聊所有这些。我希望听播客的每个人都会喜欢。我觉得如果我去杂货店看到葵花籽黄油，我会有所反应。我会想：“哼，抱歉，留着给你自己吃吧。”我憋在心里太久了，不管怎样，如果我终于把楼梯底下收拾干净了，我会在社交媒体上分享的。
Great. Good. And you know what, that was your window into our friendship. We discussed the important things. Because with your BFF, all of it's important. That's right. Yeah. I'm invested in the bottom of your stairs now.
太好了。很好。你知道吗，那是你了解我们友谊的一扇窗。我们讨论的都是重要的事情。因为对于你的闺蜜来说，所有的事情都很重要。没错。是的。我现在对你楼梯底下的情况很关心了。
I really am. Yeah. And I'm going to try a gluten-free Oreo. See, that's best friendship. Well, Michael has a talking head that he has plenty of female friends speaking of friendship. His mom, Pam's mom, his aunt, who just blocked him on IM, the lady at Quiznos, he doesn't need Pam. And we also have to mention, Pam has just found out that Jim knew.
我是认真的。是的。而且我要去尝尝无麸质奥利奥。看，这才是真正的友谊。好吧，说到友谊，迈克尔有个访谈镜头，说他有很多女性朋友。他的妈妈，帕姆的妈妈，刚刚在即时通讯软件上把他拉黑的姑姑，还有奎兹诺斯（Quiznos）三明治店的那位女士，他根本不需要帕姆。我们还得提到，帕姆刚刚发现吉姆其实早就知道了。
Even though he didn't know very long, he knew. He knew. Yeah. Pam is really mad and she feels all alone because people are saying, I think you're overreacting. She's by herself in this feeling, you know, she feels like Jim has kind of betrayed her. Well, Jim is going to try to make it up to her. He is. He confronts Dwight about the mallard.
尽管他没知道多久，但他确实知道了。他知道了。是的。帕姆真的很生气，而且她觉得自己孤立无援，因为大家都在说：“我觉得你反应过度了。”她在这种情绪中孤军奋战，你知道的，她觉得吉姆某种程度上背叛了她。好吧，吉姆要设法弥补她。他会的。他找德怀特对质绿头鸭的事。
Dwight apologizes and Jim says, you know what, wash my car as payment for your deed, right? Dwight's like, that is fine by me. And then Jim gets Pam and they're in the conference room and they have this sweet little moment where he's like, look, Dwight felt bad for you today and he's washing our car. And Pam's like, he did that for me. And then Jim starts reminiscing about Puerto Rico. He says, you know what was nice, night swimming and bi-o-bay and Pam's like, oh, say more nice things.
德怀特道歉了，吉姆说：“你知道吗，洗我的车作为你做这种事的惩罚，好吗？”德怀特说：“这对我来说完全没问题。”然后吉姆把帕姆叫了过来，他们在会议室里度过了非常温馨的一刻，他当时说：“听着，德怀特今天为你感到难过，他正在给我们洗车呢。”帕姆说：“他是为我才这么做的吗？”然后吉姆开始回忆起波多黎各。他说：“你知道什么地方很棒吗？夜间游泳和生物发光湾。”帕姆说：“哦，多说点美好的事情。”
Well, I had to know, what is bi-o-bay? Yeah. What is it? Is it popular to night swim there? Do tell. I looked it up and this is what the website Discover Puerto Rico, which is the official tourism website for Puerto Rico had to say, exploring Puerto Rico's bioluminescent bays. If you're seeking an eco-friendly, surreal experience, you should include a bioluminescent
好吧，我必须弄明白，什么是生物发光湾？是的。那是什么？在那里夜间游泳很流行吗？快讲讲。我查了一下，这是波多黎各官方旅游网站“发现波多黎各”（Discover Puerto Rico）上关于这个的介绍：探索波多黎各的生物发光湾。如果你正在寻找一种生态友好、超现实的体验，在规划下一次旅行时，你应该把波多黎各的生物发光湾列入行程。它们是罕见的生态系统，当被称为——哦，我大概会把这个词念错，甲藻（dinoflagellates）的单细胞微小生物
bay in Puerto Rico when planning your next trip. They are rare ecosystems that happen when microscopic single-sale organisms called, oh, I'm probably going to get this wrong, dinoflagellates. Sure, I got that wrong. They grow in quantities big enough to produce a glow-in-the-dark effect when stimulated by movement. So when you paddle or splash around, these organisms light up in a neon blue-green color. And so does everything they come in contact with, giving a star-like reflection to the
没错，我肯定念错了。当它们的数量增长到足够大时，受到运动刺激就会产生暗夜发光的效果。所以当你划水或嬉戏时，这些organisme（生物）会发出霓虹蓝绿色的光。它们接触到的一切东西也都会发光，给水面带来星光般的倒影。
water. They can be found throughout the ocean, however, it is very rare for them to live in high concentrations enough to be noticeable. To put this in perspective, there must be thousands and thousands of these single-sale organisms to make a gallon of water light up. There are only five ecosystems in the world where the concentration of these planktons is high enough to be considered bioluminescent bays, and Puerto Rico is home to three of them.
它们在整个海洋中都能找到，然而，它们能以足够高的浓度生活从而引人注目的情况非常罕见。为了让你有个概念，必须有成千上万个这样的单细胞生物，才能让一加仑的水发光。世界上只有五个生态系统的浮游生物浓度高到可以被称为生物发光湾，而波多黎各就拥有其中三个。
That sounds so cool. Doesn't it? I've always wanted to go to Puerto Rico. I was supposed to go there because years ago, I wrote a short film called Blacked Out, and it was directed by my friend, Andres Anglade, and edited by Juan Marquez, who are both from Puerto Rico, and it won the Crowd Favorite Award at the Rencon International Film Festival. And I started it along with my husband, Josh, Creed Bratton, my friends, Tonebill, and Makayla Hoover.
听起来太酷了。不是吗？我一直想去波多黎各。我本来应该去的，因为几年前，我写了一部名为《黑屏》（Blacked Out）的短片，由我的朋友安德烈斯·安格拉德（Andres Anglade）导演，胡安·马尔克斯（Juan Marquez）剪辑，他们都来自波多黎各，这部片子还在林孔国际电影节上获得了观众最喜爱奖。我和我的丈夫乔什、克里德·布拉特恩、我的朋友托尼·比尔和麦凯拉·霍夫尔一起出演了这部片子。
And I was unable to go to accept the award in Puerto Rico because I was in Vancouver filming Haters Back Off. Oh my gosh. Well, first of all, I remember that short film, and it's so funny. You and Josh are so good at it. It's very, very funny. Creed is hilarious in it. I need to find a way to, I don't know, I need to, I don't know where to put it.
但我没能去波多黎各领奖，因为我当时正在温哥华拍摄《痛恨者退散》（Haters Back Off）。哦天哪。好吧，首先，我还记得那部短片，太搞笑了。你和乔什在里面演得太棒了。非常非常搞笑。克里德在里面太逗了。我得想个办法，我不知道，我得——我不知道把它放在哪里。
You need a link. I need a link. I own it. I don't know how to have people watch it. But anyway, it was just a passion project of mine based on something that happened to a friend of mine. And anyway, there you go, Puerto Rico Biobay, I want to go, put it on my list. My parents are going to Puerto Rico.
你需要一个链接。我需要一个链接。版权在我手里。我不知道怎么让大家去看它。不管怎样，那只是我基于发生在我朋友身上的一件事而创作的一个充满热情的项目。不管怎样，就是这样，波多黎各生物发光湾，我想去，把它列入我的愿望清单。我父母要去波多黎各。
They are? I'm going to tell them about this. Yeah, they love Puerto Rico. They've been several times. It's like one of their favorite vacation destinations, and I've never been. They might even know about the Biobays. Well, I'm going to call them after we're finished, and I'm going to chat them up about it. Because that sounds seriously amazing.
他们要去？我要把这个告诉他们。是的，他们很喜欢波多黎各。他们去过好几次了。这就像是他们最喜欢的度假胜地之一，而我却从来没去过。他们甚至可能知道生物发光湾的事。好吧，等我们录完我就给他们打电话，跟他们好好聊聊这个。因为听起来真的很惊艳。
I know. Because everyone's leaving for the day. We have this really fun little moment. Just once again, Kevin's going to compliment Ryan's fedora, says, where did you get it? Ryan says, I'd rather not say. I don't know why I love the phrase, I'd rather not say. I want to adopt it. It's so douchey.
我知道。因为大家都下班离开去过节了。我们有了一个非常有趣的小插曲。又是凯文，他去恭维瑞安的费多拉帽，说：“你从哪儿买的？”瑞安说：“我不想说。”我不知道为什么我这么喜欢“我我想说”这句话。我想把它用起来。太装腔作势了。
It's so dismissive. I'd rather not say. Where'd you get your shoes? I'd rather not say. I mean, I want to do it. Why do I want to do that so bad? It's funny to me. Put it in your pocket, bring it out at your next cocktail party.
太傲慢了。我不想说。你鞋子在哪儿买的？我不想说。我的意思是，我很想这么做。为什么我这么想这么干？我觉得很好笑。把它揣进你的口袋里，在你的下一个鸡尾酒会上拿出来用。
I think I might. As if we have cocktail parties. I know. Okay, where are we? Well, where we are is that everybody has left, and Dwight goes into Jim's office and reveals that the true recording device was that pen that he brought in at the very beginning. And it's a fancy looking pen. And wouldn't Jim have been like, where'd I get a fancy pen and why'd I put it on Dwight's
我想我可能会。就好像我们有什么鸡尾酒会似的。我知道。好吧，我们在哪儿？好吧，我们在哪儿呢，就是大家都走了，德怀特走进吉姆的办公室，透露说真正的录音设备其实是他一开始带进去的那支笔。那是一支看起来很高级的笔。难道吉姆不会觉得“我从哪儿弄来这么一支高级笔，我为什么把它放在德怀特的桌上”吗？但话说回来，吉姆已经进入了作为老板的“迈克尔漩涡”，所以也许他错过了这些线索。
desk? But again, Jim has entered into the Michael Vortex of being a boss, so maybe he's missing these cues. That's what I'm saying. He has all these blind spots now. And Dwight is tickled because he's got eight hours of recordings to listen to. It seems like he's going to listen to him right now, tonight. I think we need to end this episode with something from the deleted scenes.
这就是我要说的。他现在有太多的盲区了。而德怀特则沾沾自喜，因为他有八个小时的录音可以听。听起来他打算现在就听，就在今晚。我觉得我们应该以被删掉的场景中的某些内容来结束这一集。
That is how Michael sums up this whole day to Jim. Stupid wedding. If I had known the outcome, I would have stopped at third base. Stupid wedding. Well, you guys, that was the lover. Thanks so much for listening and sending in your questions and comments. We love you guys. Yeah, next week we have Koi Pond, which I've already watched and absolutely loved.
那就是迈克尔向吉姆总结这一整天的话。愚蠢的婚礼。如果我早知道结果，我当初就会停在三垒了。愚蠢的婚礼。好吧，伙计们，这就是《情圣》。非常感谢大家收听并发送你们的问题和评论。我们爱你们。是的，下周我们要播《锦鲤池》，我已经看过了，绝对爱不释手。
Oh, it's a good one. We'll see you guys next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico.
哦，这一集很棒。我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾斯利·布比科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特恩的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。